so I was at the Phoenix Phoenix doing a
couple of shows my parents were there
nice and um my dad sick it was in the
hospital he's better now and but Charlie
was early was in my hotel room and we
were looking up stuff online and I I go
to this I don't know why and this is I
feel so bad about it but I go to
different cities talent agencies like
you go to their websites no yeah there's
a place there's this thing called
because back when I was on MADtv
the producers right you got you got this
website is called Philly faces yeah and
it's just a agency out of Philly no and
so then you see these they have a roster
of actors and rots no you see the reels
and so there's another one out of
Cleveland called taxi management and
agency yeah Emmanuel [ __ ] God there
is some talent on there that is so
unbelievably funny I can't and I Charlie
we how hard will be laughing like I
almost died it was one of those laughs
where you didn't hear them laugh for two
minutes because they were it was good
breathe they couldn't breathe like we
were collapsed on the ground because
there was a sequence of videos that I
have to show you in order to get you to
that point of laughter because there's a
callback isn't that oh my god there's
the there's a girl on there her entire I
know we should not be okay now we're
gonna blow up there you know I know I
want you to say say your thing but
before I you say that all right
I just want to say that we're not making
fun of these people yeah it's the dream
there it is their dream but can I just
say something cuz I've had experience
with this yeah there are certain
management companies that actually take
money from these unsuspecting people who
think that they're gonna make it and
then they pay money and they say yeah
we're gonna represent you they do this a
lot in modeling because I remember even
even here in LA yeah they'll be like oh
yeah we'll recruit you and we're a
management a week we seek out talent and
then you pay this amount and then we're
gonna represent you so this I think is
one of those places that's why I
mentioned this
so this girl's entire reel is of her
assembling a vacuum cleaner and it
doesn't even zoom into her face it's
just her head is cut off and it's just
her body
see how I see it I see what is yeah and
I think it's like her audition for QVC
and it's it's it's really sad and funny
yeah yeah I mean there's a couple of
that do have talent I'm not being like
I'm done being real yeah there was a one
older guy that like his monologues are
pretty good and whatnot but when I want
to save these people is is that you you
have a dream I want you to have a dream
and I want you to pursue your dream all
right but don't take shortcuts mmm all
right doing it there and not moving to
either New York LA is a shortcut small
marketing it's a small market what you
do is you go into a big pond with big
fish right and you compete and if you
have the talent you will rise I promise
you but some of these people and like I
was in Portland at the mall
and there was a gigantic talent show
that people paid money's are [ __ ] I
do I know with the UH with yeah with
runway runaway riot [ __ ] but the
funny thing is is that they introduced
these judges this judges from Akron Ohio
and he's you know I mean an agent out of
this thing and then they all kind of
stood up and you knew that they weren't
or not yeah these people Tina from
Auntie Anne's but what I care it's what
I did was because a couple of the
contestants recognized me so I stood
there staring at the judges and like the
house to like to disco I know what
you're doing you're scamming all these
people these this is a highway robbery
and anyone that pays money to do that is
a [ __ ] idiot
yes if you do I was telling to Charlie
this they trick a lot of these yeah I
was telling parents parents when I
started doing stand-up in 1995 the first
thing that entered my mind is this
you just I just you just know you just
know that I'm gonna go up ten thousand
times four years and I may or may not
make it but I know that that is the road
that is what I need to do to get to
where I need to go because I don't I
don't come from show business background
my parents are working-class they owned
a clothing store restaurant yeah right
they barely speak English all right I
don't have that connection so I had to
come to LA with nothing knowing nobody
and crawl my way up and I think I think
I think I did pretty good I crawled at
CAA I have great rep you know I mean
I've been on show yeah movie whatever
right but it's like if you don't know
that that's what it takes then you're
not gonna make it am I not right no Jay
Wright was it I mean Charlie Finn you
know he's been on two TV shows you know
he's ever been our guest and one of my
best buddies and uh he knows how
difficult it's difficult you know bites
you're you just came here and you
realize what it takes so anyway anyone
that like you've been given that
everything is available on the internet
now you should at the very least educate
yourself about what the process is about
like what it actually takes because back
then and I mean all of these videos that
we were looking at this quote-unquote
management it it looked like a bad
infomercial from the 90s it looked like
something that was put out in the 90s of
like and they were just scamming people
who were so unaware from these really
small towns yeah but it's like so small
markets I mean nine year olds can
operate reddit you know better than me
yeah they can but you know it's and
another thing is when people come up to
me go how do I get an agent or a manager
that works but no this is how you do it
they come to you mm-hmm
okay that's it I've never only one in
the first two years did I do headshots
after that I said [ __ ] this cuz nobody
wanted him they came to you one day Matt
called me and said
I can't get you at gross because that's
where my agent ones at the time he goes
I just became an agent but I'm gonna
look out for things for you and that's
how it started yeah but it's like and
that guy the reason why I met even knew
who I was was because he'd see me go up
a hundred times you mean at the Comedy
Store
so that's I'm just saying that that's if
you're if you wanted to ask and you're
listening I want to become an actor or
comedian that's fine do the work that's
all educate yourself he's it wrong to
even play this right now on the puppets
because some of them are so good well
they know the thing they can look it up
now they can look it up their websites
gonna crash there get so much traffic
our bandwidth everyone's watching these
reels I mean these reels are so good I
mean it some of the reels are like DVD
good no you don't even know who that
person was that you're even looking for
that's how little they're in it we're
gonna watch it afternoon I gotta be
great but anyway that's I just feel like
is that mean for me to do but I just I
just laughed at it I just
[Music]